what's up buddy
hey rich can you hear me
yeah so you want to know why attractive
women go for nerds
yeah i so a lot of my girlfriends uh in
college are
in
relationships with in ltrs with these
guys that either
they don't work out they don't
necessarily have a job or they're not
i mean they're not improving themselves
these are just
um you know frat guys or
for lack of a better term just
not necessarily the most attractive
people in the world um but for some
reason you know these girls who are very
attractive and and have a lot going for
them
for some reason settle for these guys
and it just blows my [ __ ] mind like i
don't understand why all right so so let
me ask you why do you think that is
i think that
it's easy to just
settle with for someone and you know if
if they're if they don't want to play
the the the cat and mouse game they just
they just find a guy that
will give them everything i don't know
how how
long have these uh couples been together
that you're witnessing here over six
months i mean these are you know
long-term relationships well six years
is a long-term relationship six months
for college anyways you know well
there's a long time in college yeah so
that's the point that i was going to
make i mean six months ain't that long
right so if they're hanging out with
these dorks for six months and they're
not particularly attractive like i'm
assuming like when you say losers not
attractive out of shape yeah like uh
like neck beard sort of style you know
star wars guys maybe follows like
female-led relationships on twitter sort
of thing stuff like that yes yeah those
won't last most of them it's like little
saiyans ticking down in the hourglass
and like the
the end of that relationship comes up
sooner or later those sorts of things
don't last they might be with them you
know like now like you know holding out
to the public that they're a couple sort
of thing but chances are you know
women like that that go to vegas you
know with their girlfriends or go to new
york you know for a weekend sort of
thing and they leave their boyfriends
behind
that's when the fun happens for them
right
that's why
whenever you've been a loss like you
ever been in las vegas yes
you know what happens in vegas right
yeah that's right parties girls weekends
blah blah blah like you know a lot of
these women have guys back home that's
why they're traveling together as women
right i'm always youngling so yeah the
like
women get into those relationships
because again you know it's not just men
that are plugged into comforting lives
women are too they're just like oh you
know you got to find a guy and
the the other thing that you got to
remember too is a lot of women go to go
to college university to get their mrs
degree you know their misses
so if they so if they come across a guy
in college or university that looks like
he might have a bright future but he
looks like a dork right now yeah then
you know at least she's got him on the
line right he's beta bucks for later on
down the road
but she can always tick off that you
know that itch that uh scratch you know
with the alpha seed you know with the
other guys at the parties the nightclubs
the weekends away with their girlfriends
so with a situation like that do you
recommend just you know waiting it out
until she realizes you know what what
she's doing or well hang on a second
waiting at what like are you waiting out
to find one of these like waiting for
things to slowly dissolve or do you
actively try to mate poach i mean well
when you're talking about waiting it out
you're starting to sound like beta and
waiting right
so you you definitely don't want to be
the waiting it out guy if you're a truck
see the thing that guys seem to forget
is that all women
are dealing with a guy in their life it
doesn't matter who she is
every woman you see at the grocery store
the gas station the cafeteria everywhere
you go
has a guy or guys in her life could be a
guy that she's talking to could be a
husband could be a boyfriend could be
fwb
she could be a sugar baby she could be
any number of things but she has at
least one guy in her life generally
multiple
that she's dealing with
so
when you
when you
bring a woman in your life whether
you're dating friends with benefits
whatever you're basically poaching that
chick from some other guy
somebody has to lose so
what's the question here like you know
do i poach these girls from these nerds
right
dude you're nico you're a good-looking
guy what's the problem
you don't need to ask for permission why
don't you just go do it
all right thank you rich i love your
podcast i'm i'm just reading your book
i'm also reading no more mr nice guy i
appreciate you good man yeah that's
that's uh that's a decent series of
books to uh get into for sure thanks and
get yourself thank you done with the
book on amazon do me a solid
leave me a review there just let people
know that you got some value out of
checking that out hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forge
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you